what i want to do in this video is to
provide ourselves with a rigorous
definition of what it means to take the
limit of a sequence as n approaches as n
approaches infinity and what we'll see
is it's actually very similar to the
definition of any function taking any
function as the limit approaches
infinity and this is because these
sequences really can be just viewed as a
function of their indices
so let's say
let me draw let me draw an arbitrary
sequence right over here so actually let
me draw it like this just to make it
clear what the limit is approaching so
let me draw a sequence
let me draw a sequence that is jumping
around
a little bit so let's say when n is
equal to 1
a sub 1 is there when n is equal to 2 a
sub 2 is there when n is equal to 3 a
sub 3 is over there when n is equal to 4
a sub 4 is over here when n is equal to
a sub 5 is over here and it looks like
as n is so this is 1 2 3 4 5. and so it
looks like as n gets bigger and bigger
and bigger a sub n seems to be
approaching
seems to be approaching some value
it seems to be getting closer and closer
it seems to be converging to some value
l right over here but what we need to do
is come up with a definition of what
does it really mean to converge to l
so let's say for any so we're going to
say that you converge to aleph for any
for any
epsilon greater than 0 for any positive
epsilon
you can
come up
you can get or you can there is or maybe
i'll write this way for any positive
epsilon
there is
a positive
positive
m capital m
such that
such
that
if
lowercase n is greater than capital m
then
the distance between a sub n
a sub n
and our limit
and our limit this l right over here the
distance between those two points is
less than epsilon
if you can do this for any epsilon for
any epsilon greater than 0 there is a
positive m such that if n is greater
than m then the distance between a sub n
and our limit is less than epsilon then
we can say
then we can say that the limit
of a sub n
as n approaches infinity is equal to l
and we can say that a sub n converges
converges
converges to l so let's let's let's
parse this so here i was making the
claim that this that a sub n is
approaching this l right over here i
tried to draw it as a horizontal line
this definition of the of what it means
to converge for sequence to converge
says look for any epsilon greater than
zero so let me pick an epsilon greater
than zero so i'm going to go to l plus
epsilon actually let me do it right over
here l let's say this is l
plus epsilon and let's say this is right
here this is l minus epsilon
l
minus epsilon so let me draw those two
bounds
right over here
and so i picked an epsilon here so for
any if for any arbitrary epsilon any
arbitrary positive epsilon i pick we can
find a positive m
we can find a positive m
so that as long as so let's say that
that is our m right over there so that
as long as our n is greater than our m
then our a sub n our a sub n is within
epsilon of l so being within epsilon
being within epsilon of l is essentially
being in this range this right over here
is just saying look the distance between
a sub n and l is less than epsilon so
that would be any of these anything
that's in this between l minus epsilon
and l plus epsilon the distance between
that and our limit is going to be less
than epsilon
and we see right over here at least
visually if we pick m there if you take
an n that's larger than that m
if you pick an n that's larger than m if
n is equal to 3 a sub n seems to be
close enough if n is 4 a sub n is even
getting closer it's within our epsilon
so if we can if we can say this is true
for any epsilon that we pick then we can
say we can say that the limit exists
that a sub n converges to l
in the next video we'll use this
definition to actually prove that a
sequence converges